veteran actor Harry Dean Stanton dead at  91 what I'm trying to say is you can't  make it happen you know it either will  or it won't it's all in the heart  et have learned the Hollywood legend  died of natural causes on Friday at  cedars-sinai Medical Center in Los  Angeles  oh sure myself the same way about  somebody myself  Stanton's career was an impressive one  to say the least he accumulated more  than 190 credits to his name and while  he's best known for his roles in iconic  movies like The Godfather Part 2 alien  and Escape from New York he most  recently starred in HBO's Big Love and  the Twin Peaks revival on Showtime I'm  gonna talk to you about an Andy  Stanton's pretty and pink co-star Jon  Cryer tells et he'll remember him as an  incomparable character actor with a  soulful voice quote and I suppose I'll  feel a little better knowing that soul  has found peace rest in peace Harry  [Music]